- This ain't no bean patty.
(swing music)
- Last Friday I had a burger for lunch
and then a burger for dinner.
- If you're on a desert island,
what food would you have?
Cheeseburger.
- I haven't had any like
ground or land meat for like nine years.
- I had some yesterday.
But ... (laughter)
- I heard some murmurs
that it's pretty good.
- I didn't give up meat
because it tastes bad.
So I still would love a
really solid substitute.
And I heard that this was it.
(rock music)
- Did you say bleeds?
- I'm hoping that if this
burger is as advertised
that I won't have to eat meat anymore.
- I'm expected to be disappointed.
- Oh my God.
- [Curtis] I'm pretty
excited about this right now.
(dramatic classical music)
- If I didn't know better
I would look at this and
think this is a burger.
- It actually smells like ground beef.
- Oh my God.
- It looks pretty real.
- It looks pretty juicy.
- Look. Wow!
- One, two, three ...
(dramatic classical music)
- What?
- Yep. Tastes like a burger.
- It's got a char on it,
just like a burger would.
- It kind of has that like crunch
that you sometimes miss.
- This can't not be meat.
This is impossible.
- It's really nice that you
do have to remind yourself
you're eating a veggie burger.
- This is light years ahead
of any other fake burger.
- If you close your eyes
you can taste it more.
- I'm trying not to make it
too much like a commercial,
just overwhelmingly positive,
but it really is that good.
- I literally had a burger yesterday,
and like, this is just as good.
- You ever have those
things that are so good
you just want to
concentrate on the moment.
- It looks like a real patty,
which is crazy.
- This is coming to an end
and I'm really sad about it.
- If I were on a desert island
and I asked for cheeseburgers
for the rest of my life,
and they gave me this;
I wouldn't be mad at it.
- It also makes me feel good that
eating something like this
is doing good for the environment.
- If this is the future of meatless meats,
then I'm on-board.
- Ladies and gentlemen,
that's finger-licking good.
- This is me becoming a vegetarian.
You heard it here first.
(dramatic classical music)